in times of need Banks and financial
institutions lend money to people and
businesses but a middleman is always
required in the traditional lending
procedure to make the loan application
approval and disbursement processes
which makes the process way more complex
and charges a hefty fee but this is
where blockchain comes into the picture
blockchain can solve these issues and
make this procedure much simpler how let
me tell you a blockchain is simply a
network of computer systems that
duplicates and distributes a digital
Ledger of transactions across the entire
network each block on the Chain
comprises several transactions and each
participant's Ledger receives a copy of
each new transaction on the blockchain
by establishing a ledger that no one
administers blockchain technology
enables untrusted parties to agree on
the status of a database without using a
metal
it makes use of a smart contract a piece
of code that executes on its own when
particular contract conditions are met
using smart contracts lenders and
borrowers can negotiate practical
parameters like proof of funds
requirements and payment schedules
these contracts will then authenticate
and record transactions without a bank
or middlemen enabling quicker known
applicant verification and quicker loan
distribution due to its ability to scale
transparency eliminate fraud and double
spending and reduce security threats
blockchain is an incredibly
revolutionary and exciting technology in
fact blockchain can completely redesign
any system that contains flows and human
blunders companies like JP Morgan IBM
Microsoft and Oracle are already
benefiting from the distributed model of
blockchain technology and 90 of
participants in the European payments
Council predict that by 2025 blockchain
technology will profoundly transform the
industry so that's blockchain technology
wrapped in two minutes I hope you
enjoyed this video please subscribe for
more amazing videos like this thank you
keep learning and stay tuned with simply
learn